on va parler des Jeux Olympiques on va
voir ce que les conséquences notamment
dans votre département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis à Vincent kapokanella
c'est pour ça on retrouve Jacques paquet
bonjour Jacques merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris Jacques et
justement vous y revenir sur ses Jo 2024
et interrogé le sénateur sur les enjeux
de séjour pour les collectivités
tout à fait tout à fait parce que
Monsieur capo canelas vous êtes vous
êtes j'allais dire concerné à plus d'un
titre au titre de sénateurs de
Seine-Saint-Denis qui est le département
dans lequel beaucoup de choses vont se
passer et puis commencer un maire du
Bourget qui accueillera le cluster du
des médias je crois que les équipements
sont à cheval avec la commune de Dugny
dites-nous monsieur capocana est-ce
qu'on sera prêt et vous qui est un
spécialiste des finances est-ce que vous
redoutez de nouvelles révisions à la
hausse du budget vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la hausse des taux d'intérêt
mais aussi la hausse des matières
premières
alors je pense que oui on sera prêt il y
a d'énormes efforts qui ont été faits
notamment par la solideo qui construit
les ouvrages olympiques par les
collectivités locales vous avez rappelé
que à l'époque au maire du Bourget j'ai
suivi ensuite après tout ce dossier au
Bourget mais aussi dans la ville d'aduni
avec l'établissement public Paris perda
d'envol qui est l'intercommunalité et
qui nous a nous a aidé là-dessus avec le
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis on a
essayé de construire quelque chose qui
nous donne des investissements qui
soient utiles à la population notamment
et qui pense sportif parc sportifs
réaménagé les liaisons douces des
liaisons vertes voilà plus de qualité de
vie et qui aura un héritage concret des
Jeux Olympiques donc c'est toute la
démarche qu'on a construite alors ça
aurait pu peut-être être plus large dans
la seine-saint-dime en tout cas on est
allé cette fois au-delà de Saint-Denis
et pleine commune qui traditionnellement
recevait ce genre d'événements donc là
c'est une façon aussi d'élargir si j'ose
dire les investissements publics à
d'autres communes donc ça avance je
crois de manière extrêmement positive à
ma connaissance solideo tient ses
engagements au budgétaires mais il
faudra évidemment
[Musique]
maximiser à la fois l'héritage mais
aussi le l'engagement pendant et après
la les jeux il vous semble que tout se
passe bien sur cet aspect là
c'est toujours un combat quand on est
élu local de se faire entendre de l'état
de la multiplicité d'organismes qui qui
gère ce type d'événement mais évidemment
au quotidien il y aura aussi des
perturbations il faut pas le nier mais
c'est un événement mondial
ça n'arrive qu'une fois partiel la
France a donné à voir au monde entier
qu'elle peut être aussi
une terre qui accueille de très grands
événements comme ça qui a un message je
crois que ça peut être aussi au moment
d'optimisme et que les valeurs du sport
ça compte finalement pour la jeunesse
donc il faut veiller à ce que chacun
puisse participer mais j'ai globalement
confiance dans tout ça il y a un petit
sujet quand même c'est ce sentiment que
les jeux c'est cher et notamment sur les
places je pense que ça a pas été très
bien présenté
mais c'est votre sentiment aussi il faut
des jeux plus populaires déplace moins
cher je pense que tout ça n'absence que
s'il y a pas de découplage entre le CIO
le conjo d'un côté et les territoires la
population et la suite il y a des
efforts à faire oui Jacques
oui si vous permettez je voulais changer
de sujet vous venez de rencontrer le
ministre du logement et de la ville
Olivier Klein à propos des contrats de
villes je crois que vous insistez sur
l'importance de ces contrats pour la
scène Saint-Denis notamment pouvez-vous
nous en décrire un petit peu les enjeux
j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer Olivier
Klein qui est un élu d'ailleurs de mon
département qui est l'ancien maire de
Clichy-sous-Bois avec qui j'ai une
relation cordiale et qui connaît bien le
terrain qui connaît bien les sujets de
politique de la ville bien évidemment
c'est quelqu'un qui est de très longue
date c'est investi là-dedans j'avais
participé à une commission du temps de
son sac prédécesseur sur l'avenir des
contrats de ville je sais qu'il est en
train d'y réfléchir donc c'était un
échange pour à partir du terrain et
c'est de voir quelles sont pouvaient
tirer la Seine-Saint-Denis est aussi une
terre d'expérimentation sur la politique
de la ville la question là encore c'est
qu'au moins on associe les les
populations je sais que Olivier Klein il
réfléchit donc ça fait partie des axes
de travail pour pour demain mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que la politique de
la ville c'est évidemment aussi parfois
la réparation parce qu'on a quelquefois
construit des quartiers un peu vite et
il s'agit aussi de mieux associer les
populations de soutenir la vie locale il
y a pas que l'investissement donc voilà
ça fait partie des piliers pour demain
évidemment il s'agit d'apporter les
financements qui sont attendus on est
dans une période aussi où il faut faire
attention par rapport à ça
il y a parfois des débats sur le fait
que une subvention devient récurrente et
il faut peut-être parfois examiner on
sait tous que c'est particulièrement
difficile à faire mais je souhaite que
le gouvernement avance là dessus
face au défi écologique et social c'est
à la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
merci Jacques paquet d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin
[Musique]